Let's get some practice with nested loops. This digital clock can display any
time of day. It's an American clock, so the hours go from 1 to 12 and minutes
go from 00 to 59. We can use a nested loop to print this table of all of the
possible times the digital clock can display. We'll need two loops. One will
count up the hours, and one will count up the minutes. To make sure that
minutes are printed with a zero before them so they fill up two digits, you can
use the format string %02d. And if you're not sure where to start while writing
your code, think about what code you would write just to print the first line.
And how that differs from the code that you would write to print the second
line.